hey everyone what's going on carlos
hanging out with you here it seems
fitting
that this nerd alert is happening on a
thor's day
we're talking all about loki we're here
with
two of my favorite people on
the planet i gotta tell you joining us
is sam maggs she's a writer for books
video games and comics like marvel
action captain marvel and jeff j
nerd and pop culture commentator and my
personal you don't know
you don't know this right now josh but
i'm following you on instagram you're my
like daily motivational speaker guy
you're the guy you're my dude right now
no i i need i need as equal motivation
or even more
so if it's helping you send that energy
back to me because it gets tough out
there but i'm glad
i'm happy for that all right so today we
want to talk all about loki like i said
um we're getting into season or so it
should be episode three spoilers if you
haven't watched it yet
please go watch it then come on back and
join us for the conversation also we're
gonna get a chance to talk about what we
love
um and what we think really about the
series so far
i'm sylvie now oh you changed your name
brilliant it's called an alias it's not
very low-key-like yeah
what exactly makes a loki a loki
independence authority style
i want to talk about sylvie off the top
i think that she is
uh sophie dimartino plays an enigmatic
very charismatic also
character that may or may not even be
a loki there are so many theories going
around and just the name
sylvie sparks even more theories if
people understand the
the sort of junior enchantress sort of
history of that character
sam talk to us about um sylvia and what
you think
uh what you think she's bringing to the
whole lore of loki
i think she's an amazing character and i
my overwhelming impression of her
in the most recent episode is that you
can tell that this is a show
written and directed by women starring a
woman
the scene that stands out to me is when
sylvie pops through the
the time door into the tva and she
immediately puts her hair back into a
ponytail to keep it off her face
and that one moment alone i was like aha
women made this
you know and she's wearing flat boots
and her fight scenes are so
kick butt and i just like it was such a
refreshing
female anti-hero take that we so rarely
get to see
in media in general let alone in like
mass-market pop culture
media um i was just really thrilled by
this take on her character
whomever she may be whomever she may be
and let's get into that a bit jeff
you know there's that scene where uh on
the train
where she and loki are having
conversation kind of about their
histories
talking about their mothers who you know
if she is
in fact a variant of loki then
technically speaking they
kind of should maybe have the same
mother but we don't know this yet
um what are your thoughts on maybe who
she
is what her story actually is yeah i say
this unironically i love the mystique
about her
because she can literally be anybody
right
just because freya was loki's mom
doesn't mean
that has to be hers if the multiverse is
infinite
so your your stories branch out at
different points
right so we don't have an idea of who
she is
and she's doing that tactically and she
lets him know
because the more she knows about him the
better she can prepare for
anything with him we get just enough
and why i think she may not even be a
loki
is because she was bouncing off of the
information loki was giving her
even talking about the adoption loki
brought up the adoption and she said oh
yeah i knew that a while ago
bringing up the mothers and the fact
that he was a prince she knew certain
things about him
but the information that she provided
was information based off of what loki
said
not really uh inviting or not really
offering that up herself
other than this random postman love
story that she has going on
allegedly right so right i think that
also
that also just builds the anticipation
to truly find out
who she is like i watch this episode and
i feel like
i know more about her but i still don't
know anything which is great
and that's a really good magic trick to
be able to do to an audience
is to feel like you know this character
without knowing more about them
what i think is really interesting and
very telling about what their histories
might be
is that with loki we kind of we know the
struggles that he had been through up
until this point after the first
avengers movie
but he is coming from a place where he
is royalty and we know that with sylvie
she has said
whether true or not that she's been on
the run for mostly her whole life
so the attack that they are both taking
in this conversation is vastly different
you brought up a good point jeff
where she is like listening to what loki
is saying bouncing that off because
that's
very likely a tactic she's had to use in
order to survive
all this time how about you your prince
must have been would-be princesses
or perhaps another prince
a bit of both i suspect the same as you
but nothing ever really
what's one thing that i think is very um
very cool in this episode is the thing
that was really was really newsworthy
that came out of the episode
you know kate karen had said that it was
um
one of her missions when she went on to
loki to really solidify
the idea that loki was uh bisexual
does this really mean a lot for
characters moving forward in the mcu do
you guys think
yeah i mean as a fellow disaster
bisexual myself
uh it was really nice to see that
represented on screen
i think that uh until very recently
bisexual people and especially bisexual
men were basically absent from the media
landscape
all together so again to have a public
declaration like this and something so
worldwide and popular is pretty huge and
i think that
marvel in particular has come a really
long way in
a lot of ways in terms of representation
over the last 10 years
but that next big step they really have
to take in my opinion
and what i try to do in my work for them
and as well is incorporate
more queer like lgbtq plus characters
because that's what the world around me
looks like
and what my friends look like and so i
want to you know represent that
truthfully
in media and to your point like loki's a
god
who can look like anything so why would
he also not kiss anything
you know what do you hope to see moving
forward from the characters that are
gonna be introduced
later on after this sort of phase comes
to an end
well above all else i hope they're
written well i hope they're in there
you know so that they they can build off
of that and
uh generate that interest so that people
are
enthralled with them love them want to
represent them want to cosplay them
at all future comic cons and con and
halloween parties and everything you
want that representation to be
great representation not representation
just for the sake of
right i was told that everyone who works
at the tva was created by the
timekeepers
that's ridiculous they're all variants
just like us
they don't know that getting back to uh
that conversation that
loki and sylvia were having in the
episode one of the big bombshells that
she kind of drops
is that the tva are not created for the
tva
they're actually all variants does
mobius
have a jet ski in another life has he
actually ridden one
that's like that's my what i'm hoping is
the final scene in like the whole series
is that flashback like he was on
baywatch or
something like that would be really
really
i do believe sylvie about this though i
don't think she has any reason to lie to
loki
about this and we saw that flashback of
her like in the other
uh tva workers memories um so it seems
pretty convincing my question is
is mobius in on it and lying to loki
or is this genuinely like his truth and
does he like truly believe that he was
created for this and has never lived a
previous
life i kind of lean towards the second
one but knowing what we know about
mobius in the comics
i'm not sure so curious to see how that
plays out because mobius is like my
favorite character in the show right now
well they're all kind of my favorite but
i do love him yeah sam i agree with you
i'm
i'm fully bought in to the mobius jet
ski
angle i forget is jet ski somewhere
somewhat somewhere down the line i want
him to get the jet ski like i'm not even
a jet ski
guy like that but i love to see people
who have
interest be able to live those interests
and he just
they mentioned the jet ski now they have
to show us the jets that's it
that's it as far as like the tva being
variants that just goes
back to my my theory that the tva is not
to be trusted
they're like the dmv on steroids and if
you've been to the dmv it's like the
seventh level of hell
so why would you trust those type of
organizations and anything that they say
even with casey right casey never saw a
fish
he didn't know what a fish was i'm like
okay either one of two things happened
they created you specifically to be
a time accountant or there's something
else going on
i i don't know what the something else
is so now that we
we have this information that makes me
think where
and when do they come from because she
don't even say
i had to dive into our memory from
hundreds of years ago
so how long was uh
hunter c20 i believe her name was how
long was she alive
how how is time moving and are they from
pruned earths or current ones
that young soldier from the tda her mind
was
messed up everything clouded i had to
pull a memory from hundreds of years
prior
okay before we go favorite thing
favorite moment
um in this past episode for both of you
sam let's start with you
when sylvie takes off her diadem and
stabbed one of the bad
like the her antagonists with it during
a fight
basically all of sylvie's fight scenes
uh were
immaculate i was thrilled um but that
moment in particular i i
definitely shouted out loud nice good
and her scream more
yes be angry about men
who mess up their plans relatable
relatable ask ask my wife about it
it happens all the time hey carlos we
just nod and say yes
yep a hundred percent i just said you're
right
uh for me it was loki's loki's asgardian
ballad on the train
because if you've never gotten drunk in
a public place and started singing then
you haven't really lived
life right to sylvia everybody
and the call back to him taking the
drink and smashing it on the floor and
saying another
from when thor did it in like a diner
and they're like dude like what are you
doing you know how much that cost
so i like the the cultural ties of how
they
party and how they how they get together
and celebrate in asgard
being interdimensional across time and
space
and just seeing brothers right right
yeah exactly so
that was one of my underrated parts of
episode three
i was a big fan of the final scene that
one shot
that they did when they are actually
over there by the art i thought that was
beautifully done
and such a difficult thing to to pull
off to coordinate
and whether or not there were little
cuts in between that you could kind of
pick out if you're nitpicking it's the
effect was still there
it looked amazing it was a great episode
all right i want to thank you both for
joining me for this all right everyone
thank you so much for joining us
for this special edition of nerd alert
we'll be back next week for even more
loki
uh catch you then
[Music]